back in September of 2013 total war Rome
2 was released to critical acclaim
gamers on the other hand had issues that
ruin their experience total war games
always accomplished connecting the
player to historic moments in history
from the Romans to the samurai all the
while allowing the player to have full
control of how to govern their empire
and how they would like to wage war with
their neighboring nations despite having
a more user-friendly interface training
mode improved graphics from previous
total war games rome 2 suffered from
massive game breaking bugs dimwit AI
holded multiplayer connection issues and
a painful been-there-done-that feel for
its campaign rome - needless to say was
dead on arrival for hardcore RTS fans
and it made many diehard fans of the
series such as myself fear that this
could be the end for one of the greatest
RTS franchises in gaming history
[Music]
fast forward to 2016 with the release of
total war Warhammer based on the popular
brutal and bloody tabletop miniature war
game by Games Workshop which has been
around since 1983 for the longest time I
wanted a fantasy based total war game
creating your own lower the ring style
battles with the option to rule of realm
of dark magic well finally total war
took a leap of faith and it paid off
from orcs vampires dwarves elves beasts
men humans the list goes on for what
faction you can play in the campaign
each more diverse than the last my
favorite is the vampires because you
know raising an army of the undead to
rain hell on the other races priceless
past solo wargames didn't have the
spinning of experimentation but here the
free feeling of an innovative campaign
structure built around complex races
with every choice feeling like an
experiment for success or all-out war
recaptures the series in a great way
another thing that warhammer nailed is
the world itself from lush green valleys
of the empire volcanic badlands of the
orcs to the terrifying swamps of the
undead
all of which plays a bigger part on the
battlefield each battlefield showcases
fantasy based realms from towering
marble stone besieged castles to the
spiderweb covered tunnels of the dwarfs
all in amazing detail also I haven't
seen detail like this in a total war
game when it comes to the characters
before from blood sweat of a
battle-hardened orc or a dark grizzled
look of a vampire lord it just feels
like creative assembly was given a
chance to let loose with their
creativity I actually feel like I'm in
that chaotic world where every move I
make could lead to the rise or fall of
another race it is this feeling that has
led me to throw in 114 hours into the
game with no regrets
diplomacy in the battle structure of
Warhammer have finally returned total
war to its roots past total war gains
made it too easy to forge alliances with
other nations set up trade routes
through enemy territory to your allies
with little to no worry of losing goods
to enemy settlements this is no longer
the case in Warhammer now the a I will
make diplomatic decisions based not only
on world affairs but how they judge you
by your faction strength both by your
military and political standings to your
neighbors break1 trade or peace treaty
you set up and the other races will take
notice making it much harder to win them
over in political deals later even other
races that are your kin are hard to
convince to be anything more than trade
partners if you mess up a deal all of
this makes Warhammer a much deeper
challenge and past total war games the
care and thought that goes into making
the right moves of diplomacy also goes
into the battle system no more mindless
mosh pits of idiot AI fighting each
other but now fully structured battle
formations many of which differ
depending on your race orcs and beast
men are best at hit and run tactics
whether as the vampires focused on
overwhelming numbers and the other races
offer different tactics as well also the
modding community is at its strongest
coming up with great mods from campaign
resource booths
to even creating new units from scratch
all from the Warhammer lor overall this
is the structure of total war I've
missed over the years compelling war and
diplomacy campaigns with a ferocious
battle system to top it off overpriced
DLC has been a plague in the Total War
series for years with Rome to being the
main perpetrator Warhammer in some ways
has learned from this since its release
there have been four free Lord
characters two new campaigns with new
races along with three minor two
characters each DLC packs over all of
which rounds up to over 65 bucks us it's
worth putting down the cash given that
it'll add over another 20 hours or so to
your experience each new faction leader
has new and different abilities and the
DLC restructures the world adding in
races by expanding the map it is
improvement over Rome two DLC charges
giving us new races along with new
campaigns to conquer but seriously Sega
and Creative Assembly always charging
money for adding in blood and guts
really really so does this game clear
Sega and creative assembly out of the
doghouse from previous total war games
not quite but it's a great start and it
shows that a fantasy setting may be the
winning goal the series is needed I
would like to see the Total War series
to improve its battle system with more
realistic fighting animations
build your own race our faction feature
from scratch and push for a new setting
say World War one or World War two
something to really challenge the
franchise so that doesn't go stagnant
ever again they don't need to release a
new total war game every few years so
long as creative assembly is allowed to
be creative with their work in a gaming
world where RTS games are becoming more
and more rare it's good to know that
total war is still putting up a fight to
stay alive for more and more hammer in
your favorite games keep it here on
GameSpot Hey want to send both the goals
[Music]
next realization be torn asunder the
endless begin